une page économie à présent pour évoquer
dans le 7-8 là une filière qui recrutent
cette filière c'est celle d'expert
comptable alors que le chômage explose
notamment au mois d'octobre je vous
donnais les chiffres tout à l'heure nous
allons parler de cette opération
séduction qui a été lancé par les
experts comptables
on parle de jusqu'à seize mille postes
qui seraient nécessaires et qui serait
vacante disponibles on va en parler avec
l'invité sur ce plateau juste après ce
reportage
opération séduction je vous lise est
l'une d'entre elle s est organisé au
chesnay c'était il ya quelques jours on
nous considérons nous comme des gens
très triste de leur oui j'ai des cheveux
blancs des lunettes etc
il a de l'humour laurent courquin quand
il parle de son métier un métier bien
mal connu et souvent mal connoté celui
d'experts comptables il est également
commissaire aux comptes deux professions
distinctes la première dépend du
ministère des finances et l'autre du
ministère de la justice
un expert comptable c'est un conseil de
l'entreprise et c'est celui qui assure
la fiabilité des chiffres dans une
entreprise quelle que soit sa taille
le commissaire aux comptes est celui qui
assure la fiabilité des chiffres c'est
non quelqu'un d'indépendant comme
l'expert comptable d'ailleurs mais c'est
quelqu'un d'indépendant et qui certifie
les comptes qui sont publiés par
l'entreprise
ce jour-là au channel est venu avec ses
confrères à la rencontre de 600 jeunes
franciliens une vraie opération
séduction
c'est un des métiers qui est à la
rencontre de tous les autres métiers
donc en fait son contraire de quelque
chose d'extrêmement diversifiée donc
c'est un des messages qu'on veut faire
passer ces métiers nécessitent sept à
huit années d'études après le bac mais
son porteur
les besoins en expert comptable et
commissaire aux comptes sont estimées à
16000 postes dans les dix prochaines
années avec des salaires bruts de départ
compris entre 28 milles et 30000 euros
par an de quoi convaincre que ce n'est
pas un métier si triste que cela
pour mieux comprendre pourquoi cette
filière d'experts comptables manque
cruellement deux candidats je reçois
leurs encours qu'un bon soir pour ce que
vous êtes élue à la compagnie régionale
des commissaires aux comptes à
versailles on l'a vu avec ce reportage
la profession entend séduire elle doit
attirer les jeunes les besoins sont
réels
comment vous expliquer cette situation
que la profession d'expert comptable
soit aussi peu sexy oui c'est vrai alors
c'est bon on doit avoir certainement
notre part de responsabilité
effectivement dans cela mais c'est vrai
que c'est la raison pour laquelle on
fait un certain nombre d'opérations de
cette nature parce que il ya une
importance est un message fort à porter
qui en fait qu'ils aient beaucoup de
diversité beaucoup de diversité de
postes beaucoup de diversité de tâches
et quand on réfléchit bien ce métier est
un des rares métiers dans lequel on est
en contact tous les autres métiers et on
s'adresse à limite de l'artisan des
personnes privées jusqu'aux entreprises
multinationales
bien entendu il faut des spécialités des
spécifications et des spécialités mais
il y a une extrêmement grande diversité
donc ce qui fait que quels que soient la
nature le caractère de la personne qui
est intéressé par ce genre d'étude
il y avait de la place pour tout le
monde est-ce que cet hymne d'opérations
comme celle qui était organisée au
chesnay convient de voir il ya quelques
instants et véritablement efficace on
l'espère ce qu'il faut voir c'est que ce
type d'opération on le fait depuis
plusieurs années et donc c'est un
message important que l'on veut montrer
et de montrer que effectivement
justement on est des gens comme les
autres
il ya toujours un prennent d'image par
deux du public en général est
principalement des jeunes ou le métier
d'expert comptable considéré comme
quelque chose d'assez das est restée
rébarbatif et donc 7,7 ce système de
communication ce mode de communication
qui se fait donc sur une assez grande
échelle puisque c'est quand même avec
l'académie de versailles
et puis le lycée de sèvres ça permet au
contraire de parler à des jeunes et des
jeunes qui sont en fait en train de
commencer à réfléchir à leur avenir et à
savoir ce qu'ils vont faire par la suite
donc disons que sur le moyen terme je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui est
important d'autant plus que ce qui se
fait dans la région de versailles et des
yvelines se fait aussi ailleurs dans les
autres régions pour pouvoir attirer et
donc faire passer un certain nombre de
messages
l'idée c'est de les attirer dans des
filières dans ces filières qui forme aux
professions d'expert comptable comment
on devient
expert-comptable d'ailleurs alors pour
devenir l'espère contraint me lie à ça
c'est un désavantage aussi me
semble-t-il c'est qu'ils aient plusieurs
filières possibles plusieurs modes de
formation il ya d'abord la formation
universitaire c'est à dire qu'il y a
effectivement donc une le système donc
qu'est d'ailleurs qui rentre dans le
système européen de licence maîtrise et
puis dr
donc il y a des maîtrises qui existe
dans l'université il peut y avoir il ya
aussi la filière professionnelle et le
jeune qui le souhaite peut le faire
étape par étape
sachant qu'à chaque étape il y a un
diplôme un diplôme en tant que tel peut
importe le nom mais qui est reconnue et
qui est reconnue sur le marché du
travail
donc ça permet effectivement de pouvoir
s'arrêter si on le souhaite parce que la
vie peut avoir pour effet de s'arrêter à
un certain moment est de donner la
possibilité aussi effectivement des
experts comptables et par ailleurs il ya
une filière professionnelle
professionnels donc avec un certain
nombre de diplômes qui sont reconnus
bien entendu donc par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale qui permet de 2 à
des gens d'horizons différents et c'est
d'ailleurs à des sous et aussi de la
profession parce qu'on s'ouvre à
beaucoup de métiers qui tournent autour
de la communication la communication
financière à travers les entreprises et
donc ceci fictivement me permets
puisqu'il ya différentes un axe d'entrée
permet à des gens d'horizons différents
de pouvoir rentrer dans ce cursus est un
profil type
quand on aime un pré requis peut devenir
expert qu'après bien anthony faut passer
il faut passer un sale nombre d'examens
donc il ya oui un profil type sûr qu'il
faut aimer quand même une certaine
rigueur mais je crois que il ya les
chiffres il faut aimer les chiffres
voilà il faut s raid
voilà tout à fait il faut aimer les
chiffons les sentir si la fonction tout
le fictivement presque avant une
sensibilité mais il faut bien voir qu'à
travers les chiffres c'est surtout ce
qui est important c'est ce qu'il ya
derrière
est ce qu'il ya derrière c'est ça qui
est passionnant c'est d'en parler avec
les chefs d'entreprise doit parler de
leurs problématiques
donc ça veut dire que des gens qu'une
sensibilité certes technique mais qui
n'est pas que technique
au contraire peuvent réussir de très
belles carrières dans notre profession
juste une parenthèse quelle est la
différence entre un expert comptable et
commissaire aux comptes parce que les
besoins portent sur 7 de profession
louis alors les besoins portent sur ces
deux professions expert comptable alors
d'ailleurs peut-être pour situer les
choses ce sont dans les deux cas des
professions réglementées une qui est
réglementé par
sous tutelle du ministère des finances
c'est la profession d'expert comptable
et le commissaire aux comptes lui est
sous tutelle donc du ministère de la
justice
voilà donc ce qui veut dire qu'un expert
comptable c'est celui qui est le conseil
de l'entreprise
celui qui aide les entreprises à établir
la fiabilité de ces chiffres et qui
établit aussi les déclarations fiscales
ou qui peut aider ou qu'il les revoit et
qui par ce bien là d'ailleurs étonné que
c'est un axe donc aucune foi
d'informations extrêmement important
même vital dans une entreprise permet à
partir de ces chiffres d'avoir des d un
certain nombre de dialogues d'entretien
pour éclairer et pour aider le dirigeant
sur tel ou tel aspect donc une activité
de conseil
le commissaire aux comptes c'est
quelqu'un qui certifie les comptes dont
contredit qui assure la fiabilité des
comptes vis-à-vis des tiers
et pour ce faire donc il a aussi une
démarche donc être rigoureuse bien
entendu et qui nécessitent aussi
d'ailleurs beaucoup dialogue parce que
là ça nécessite de comprendre finalement
les process qui existe dans une
entreprise il certifie et les conti
fictivement après donc sont déposés au
greffe du tribunal de commerce et les
besoins sont réels dans ces deux
professions nous en parlons depuis tout
à l'heure et ce malgré le contexte
économique difficile comme il manque
cruellement de main d'oeuvre de jeune
pour devenir ensuite expert comptable
commissaire aux comptes même ça signifie
qu'ils sont bien payés c'est recherché
alors d'ailleurs c'est je crois que
c'était dit un peu oui effectivement
c'est dire que d'une manière générale
les ce qui n'était pas le cas peut-être
il ya dix quinze ans mais maintenant
c'est tout à fait le cas mulliez vous
avez raison au fait qu' une certaine
raréfaction il y à bien en tenue à
l'alignement donc des salaires sous les
autres sont les salaires qui peut être
proposé donc en entreprise
donc le ce qui a été dit dans le
reportage où on parle effectivement de
25 à 30 mille euros donc donc comme
salaire de départ est tout à fait réelle
et le deuxième aspect qui est important
c'est que dans les cabinets il ya une
formation permanente extrêmement
importante puisqu'il ya beaucoup
d'examens il ya beaucoup de choses à
savoir parce qu'il ya la fiscalité le
droit et c'est donc beaucoup d'éléments
et il ya une ambiance assez jeune même
si ça peut paraître bizarre en regardant
mais il ya une ambiance assez jeunes ce
qui est beaucoup de jeunes
systématiquement dans les andes dans
l'est dans les cabinets et donc
l'élimination entre eux vous cherchez
que des jeunes pour justement combler un
petit peu le manque actuellement est ce
que vous regardez aussi différents
profils des reconversions
professionnelles par exemple il ya les
deux joueurs dans la même optique que
effectivement le chômage est très
présent il ya peut-être des gens qui
s'interrogent pour se reconvertir
professionnellement
oui tout à fait il ya les deux bien
entendu où il ya toujours beaucoup de
jeunes que nous recrutons régulièrement
ça ça va de soi mais également pour
avoir d'aidé des formations ou des
aspects de formation complémentaire on
recrute aussi des gens qui sont plus
expérimentés pour avoir des spécialités
ou division complémentaires des nôtres
merci leur encore qu'un jour ces
explications n'hésitez pas à vous
renseigner également auprès donc de la
compagnie régionale des commissaires aux
comptes de versailles pour plus
d'informations le site internet qui
s'est affichée vous en avez l'habitude
merci à vous on reste dans l'économie
avec cet autre actualité si les experts
comptables recrute certaines entreprises
rencontrent elles des difficultés
alcatel lucent a communiqué aujourd'hui
le détail des suppressions de postes en
france sur le site de vélizy 3 162
emplois sont condamnés
les syndicats se disent plus que jamais
mobilisés sur place johanna soudry et
patrick jacques de dixmude
les premiers chiffres sont tombés
alcatel lucent va supprimer 934 potes
dans tout l'hexagone
le site de vélizy et le plus fortement
touché avec une suppression de 3 162
emplois ici il s'agit principalement de
métiers de support et de commerce
ce qu'on nous explique c'est que en
réduisant les commerciaux on va avoir
moins de possibilités de
de trouver des contrats comme on aura
moins deux contre un on aura moins de
chiffre d'affaires et on va encore nous
dire bah écoute ayant moins de chiffre
d'affaires faut encore réduire d emploi
se représente plus de 17% des effectifs
du site qui doivent disparaître
d'après la direction pour le moment il
faut mettre en place une période de
volontariat qui va s'étaler sur deux
mois mais sur deux mois à partir de la
fin de la procédure qui démarre juste
aujourd'hui donc on prend ce que sa
blessure de la période 2 avril mai juin
on sait pas exactement quand les gens
seront des lettres en dix ans et voilà
vous avez été désigné dans les critères
sociaux fait partie de tel métier vous
avez telles conditions
vous êtes licencié au revoir autre coup
de massue pour les salariés d'alcatel la
confirmation de la fermeture du site de
vélizy
les employés se verrait délocaliser dans
l'essonne sur le site de noël c'est ici
qu'on redémarre et l'histoire quasiment
d'alcatel en france et des
télécommunications modernes la
téléphonie sans fil a démarré ici à
vélizy et le faire mais c'est vraiment
un signe très fort à la france à nos
clients et aux groupes pour les
syndicats l'heure est au rassemblement
c'est vrai ou c'est un appel à la grève
nous non pêchés pas les champs de
rentrée on empêchait pas les gens de
venir travailler mais qu'on voulait
quand même qu ils soient avec nous parce
que bon on a encore des idées d'actions
derrière est vraiment sans les salariés
on peut pas faire prochaine action de
mobilisation jeudi 6 décembre au siège
d'alcatel lucent à paris allez donc y
suite à l'assemblée générale qui s'est
tenue ce matin sur le site de vélizy les
salariés ont décidé d'envahir la réunion
du comité central d'entreprise la
réunion qui a donc été interrompue une
autre réunion officielle devrait se
tenir le 13 décembre pour la mise en
place du plan social chez alcatel lucent
france